日本の歯医者
第二章
白いカウンターの向こう側で、マスクをした清楚なお姉さんが静かに書類の整理をしている。
マスクで顔が見えないので僕は自然と他のところに視線を向ける。
ピンク色の真珠のピアス。
どことなくロシアの体操選手を思い出させる茶髪のポニーテール。
細長い素の爪。
それに、純粋さを思わせると同時に、なんだかエロい雰囲気を醸し出す看護婦の制服。
青いスリッパまで一通り眺めてから、僕はマスクの方に視線を戻した。
すると、どんな口元を隠しているのか分からない白い布は、
想像力と男性ホルモンを刺激して、
革製ソファに座っている僕を素人AV監督にしてしまった。
「今日はどうされましたか？」
「歯の痛みが……」
「それから、」
「心の痛みが…」
「まあ、それは……いけませんね」
「特別な治療をしなければ」
「他の部屋にお入りになって少々お待ちください……」
「すぐにあの道具を持って参りますので」
コスプレ妄想を膨らませているうちに、カウンターの後ろのドアからもう一人ほっそりしたお姉さんが出てきて、
そっと受付の椅子に腰を下ろした。
それを見て
僕は脚を組んだ。
もし…
映画『ダーティ・ダンシング』のヒロインが２０年ほど朝昼晩マックを食べていたら、
そんな感じのぽっちゃりしたくるくるヘアの中年女が、
くちゃくちゃガムを噛みながら、新聞のクロスワードをやっている。
ときどき鉛筆の消しゴムを唇に当てながら、
と呟く。
大きな金色フープイヤリングをして、
「バーバラ」という白いネームプレートを胸に付けている。
それから部屋の空気がムシムシしているっていうのに、
安っぽい毛皮のマフラーをしている。
おしゃれのつもりなんだろうが、
むしろ車に撥ねられて死んだタヌキを適当に水で洗って首に巻いたように見える。
僕は、埃まみれのスノーグローブと９０年代に流行ったおもちゃ『ビーニー・べイビー』の豚を乗せたカウンターの前で立ち止まる。
バーバラばあさん、ふっと顔を上げた。
「あっ…　ん…」
「『E』で始まる大きな動物、知らない？」
彼女はクオーターパウンダーの臭いがする。